[Music]
lucas is here in tri-cities washington
hi lucas how are you
how you doing dave john
hey uh i got a question for you i need
your advice um
my family's grown and my wife she's
looking for a bigger house
and we currently own three
uh ones paid off we have about 200 000
between the other two
and so i'm just looking for some advice
and direction on whether keeping
property selling one or
i don't know
so i'm calling so
you you want to do
you want to sell one why
well i don't want to sell one i need a
bigger one my family's uh outgrown the
one that we're in oh i see yeah
you said your wife wants one do you want
one too
yeah happy wife happy life so uh well
okay yeah we're ready all right so we're
moving up in house
your current residence will sell for how
much
uh right now around 300 and the house
you're gonna buy would cost how much
well
uh if she gets her way probably six
six fifty
you know somewhere in that price at some
point we have to make a wise decision
together rather than just making a
princess happy so what are we gonna do
here let's be a grown man and a grown
woman what price range of home are we
actually going to buy
let's go on the high side 650. all right
so you need 350 000 more than your house
yes where are we going to get that
um
that's that's kind of what i'm i'm
looking for advice on uh do you have 350
000
in an investment that is not retirement
uh
almost yes that we own a house and it's
paid off and it's worth about 325.
okay so would you rather sell it
and your personal residence or sell your
investments and your personal residence
to pay cash for 650.
those are your two choices
well
i guess sell on the the paid off one
that's what the wife wants to do
and
you know the market where we're at as
far as renting
you know
we our initial idea was to have a house
for each one of our kids for school
and then you know when they get old
enough that's going to pay for the
school but
right now i don't know if that's
possible wanting a bigger house so
i guess
selling
selling the one that's paid off square
feet do you live in
about
17 150
how many kids do you have
i have three what ages
uh one three and seven
okay
you have a zoo yeah you're in it now
yeah you are in it to win yeah
okay so yeah yeah a little more space
would make a little more sanity i agree
with
that um yeah
what do you make of here
um i'm around 100 000.
does she work outside the home
she does
okay all right
so i want to i want you to reframe this
conversation i don't like the way the
conversation is being answered every
time i ask a question okay i don't
either for the sake of your for the sake
of your relationship and your sanity
okay
proverbs says who can find a virtuous
wife
a virtuous wife
for her worth is far above rubies the
heart of her husband safely trusts her
and he will have
no lack
of
gain
so there is tremendous wisdom
in your wife as a grown woman
not as a princess with a red face
stamping her foot that she wants
something
but your wife is a grown woman and you
connecting and saying
we
decided
that with a 100 000 income and three
littles
we want to move to a
575 thousand dollar house
that is our budget we are not going to
go over that we are going to liquidate
our home and the investments to pay cash
for that that leaves us with one rental
home which means our next goal will be
to buy two more rental homes because we
had a goal of one rental home per kid to
pay for their college or something like
that that we together develop a plan
that gives our family a better standard
of living square footage-wise but is not
you responding to well my wife wants to
sell this my wife wants to do this and
my wife wants to do that i'm getting
tired of hearing what your wife wants
exactly take ownership
sure i understand
yeah she she just started working as a
as a teacher as well so
sure she's she's got a an income pretty
close to mine as well that's awesome so
you got a 200 000 of your income you can
accomplish some of these goals but my
point is not that her opinion doesn't
matter it's that it does matter and so
does yours and you don't have the you
don't get the privilege of blaming her
for these decisions you don't agree with
and you go along with or worse you do
want to do these things it just sounds
cool to like be with a couple of dudes
at the water cooler talking about the
old ladies that are getting no man we
want to get a bigger house
well so she wants to sell i don't
i
i want to look at to where because
there's a age gap between us i want to
be able to retire when i can retire
and and
the cost is you live in 1700 square feet
with three littles and it's driving
there by nuts
that's the cost you got to change your
picture brother you had it you had an
awesome goal and then life threw
something at you and now it's time to
change your change goals yeah what your
200 000 household income paying cash for
575 000 house is not a bad place to be
it's better than most yeah and still
owning another and still owning another
rental that's paid for and you have no
payments in the freaking world at that
point and you guys can pile up some cash
and buy some other rentals and do some
other stuff
uh so yeah it's just a different picture
so you're you're that nothing's ever
going to work out exactly like we always
thought it was going to when we were 20.
yeah because we didn't understand stuff
420. oh when we were 30 oh when we were
40. oh when you're 60. right nothing
ever comes exactly like you think it's
going to but you have to learn to
navigate this together and use the
wisdom
two opposites attract and larry
briquette used to say if if
if op is a good thing opposites attract
because if you weren't opposite one of
you be unnecessary
so you need each other to complete the
picture of wisdom
and lean in on that